you know what's about to happen fancy
handsome people who pretend to be other
people look very clean let's talk about
what they wore it's nemi fashion revue
also there were so many people it's
Emmys it's guaranteed that I will not
review some of the people that you
really want me to so you should
interpret that as a personal attack from
me to you let's do this sandy Newton oh
you look like you're ready for prom you
look so beautiful but your face also
looks sneaky like your best friend just
hooked up with a guy that you liked at
school and she's having a kids Aneta and
you decided to show up in the same dress
as her but in a different color
oops and you end up shooting the guy
that she made out with anyway
cute Reese Witherspoon yes I love this
I'm getting Elle Woods Harvard
flashbacks and I love it
I'm also getting hot flashes not as fond
of them this is like sexy executive
roleplay where you walk into the bedroom
and you're like guess what's under here
ideas innovative ideas under this hair
is a brain that is powerful I'm a
goddamn successful executive treat me
like one and my cooter you Julia Louie
Dreyfus oh you look like like like like
the Oscars came all over your dress or a
me or the Tony any of them it's very
cute you don't age which kudos to you
but it does look like a beautiful
silhouette cute Priyanka Chopra whoa
this is like you might have been at like
a furry convention earlier in the day
and you had to get ready for the Emmys
and you couldn't get the costume off
completely so you can just let it just
leave it around the ankles she's a woman
on the go there's like a sexy gladiator
that's slowly transforming into the
abominable snowman we don't know which
way but cute your mole team Sarah
Paulson I love Sarah Paulson and this is
a look you look like you're going to a
tease from in New Jersey but also you've
been homeschooled for a long time but
like you're really well liked and well
adjusted and grounded and we think
you're great are you avoiding a flask is
that flask or is that just a bag that
looks like a flash mm-hmm see how much I
know about fashion cute zoe kravitz Oh
eleganza gay rocker sexy she editorial
Pokemon pinata the ten year old's
birthday party Charizard
I know pokemons cute Gabrielle Union
whoa you look like a mother-in-law
funeral and you are really glad that
[ __ ] is dead yeah
every Rachel would oh I love when women
wear and dragoness slash more masculine
inspired clothing this is very like
prince of the royal wedding up top and
then something celine dion would wear on
the bottom and I'm super into this
allison janney how do you how'd you
happen to your body and how did you look
like the how are your boobs how and how
how also how laura dern I love Laura
Dern she has the nicest human in the
universe she looks beautiful I love this
sparkled almost lace kind of like ice
dancer from Russia up top and then /a
guitarists hair all around the bottom
elegant meets edgy you Susan Sarandon
wow you look so good scientists um Susan
Sarandon is proving that gravity might
not exist so cute Jane Krakowski yeah
someone empty out the kitchen cabinets
cuz we got a lot of chest plates coming
in the Sammy's cute Nicole Kidman oh so
precious so ageless you don't age and it
makes me angry happy confused bewildered
and inspired you never missing Deborah
is not messing around
what is this what are this it's like the
sexiest use of saran wrap I've ever seen
q Jamie Woodley can do any hair color
how dare you be so good at that and also
good at being good you give back to the
world and Kat dang the blonde in the
green it looks great did great a job
you're great you're good at everything
it's stressing me out
biola davis barnes you glad to see me
yes i am i'm very glad to see you you
are all so wonderful and orange looks
great on you I don't know what else to
say about this you
look fantastic I'm getting mad because
everyone looks great I'm not mad I'm
encouraged Leslie Jones what wow this
looks very like our office holiday party
is that Caesars casino this year and I'm
showing up for it up top and then I hope
everyone took the week off because
Leslie's got legs for days down the
bottom yeah Gina Rodriguez how foolish
that kitchen cabinet we got another
chess play
coming in hot you look great you always
look good someone on chopped went too
fast and cut off all of their fingers
and then was like begging you for help
before you walked out the door and just
I'm sure you get it yeah Michelle
Pfeiffer now someone in Hollywood please
start aging Rachel bloom everyone looks
good everyone looks good everyone looks
good it's like got Doyle ease up time
and then just simple elegant understated
on the bottom two Gillian Anderson what
when did she become Portia de Rossi also
a maroon velvet how dare you it's like
you took high school theater drapes and
then you just elegant the [ __ ] out of it
yeah Julie Bowen aren't you the most
elegant stegasaurus in town cute Lea
Michele a belt and pockets may as well
wear pants but I like it I love a deep
purple who doesn't
very Barney but way better way way
better
that dinosaur this is deal I need oars
Ariel winter whoa kakigori
with this dress if winter won't be the
thing coming her boyfriend
sex cue kate mckinnon
this is so elegant and understated and
chic and she's cray and I'm getting my
shoulders going up again because I'm
just uncomfortable with how happy and
good everyone is Tracee Ellis Ross this
is son Trey sales are also was like I
see what you're doing with all of your
dresses I'm gonna take all of that put
it in one dress and wear that one it's
their bracket Ripper meet Sarah Paulson
meets Lea Michele and I don't hate it
you Samantha B this is beautiful you
look like the sexy mayor of Emerald City
and everyone abides by the law in your
town yeah Jessica Biel
well I'm swear
Dawei be my friend it almost is like a
fancy mullet meets I'm might be hosting
a key party later ensemble and I love it
too Margaret Atwood look I don't know
much about The Handmaid's Tale please
don't get upset I have to catch up but
this woman look she's look at her face
and this woman actually walked into your
house because she forgot where she lived
you'd be like stay hangout the charm
just oozes out of her happy happy face
also she looks like she knows some
secrets like she's been in your house
before not on accident she knows some
things about you that a lot of people
shouldn't know now you let her come over
whenever she wants yeah Shannon purser
barb where's barb I just thought the
Emmys looking adorable you look like you
just won miss Emerald City and no one
contested the results because you're a
cute Sophia Vergara
oh wow well you bet you're in the middle
of getting married but then you found
out that your soon-to-be husband was
cheating on you so you got out of there
and stumbled on the Emmys and you were
like I'm still gonna make this dress
work this was $10,000 I got it at
Kleinfeld I said yes to this dress yeah
many more whoa I don't want one
black swan' ballerina skirt I want all
of them cute Laverne Cox No by that I
mean yes god damn it ow ow my senses cue
Millie but it Brown ah you look like
you're the flower girl
so if you ever come to my wedding and so
when she ran out you were like rude girl
power and ran in after her and then made
it work you the boys from stranger
things look good again always why don't
other men at award shows dress as
awesome as these kids dress you guys
look like the best boyband I've ever
seen but you also have like PhDs and
respect women dude okay that's it for my
Emmys fashion review let me know who
your favorites were in the comments down
below again there were so many people
I'm sorry I couldn't get to everyone but
tried my best if you like these kind of
videos give this video a thumbs up and
like subscribe to this YouTube channel
hit that little Bell notification so you
get notified when I post videos because
it's wildly inconsistent that's part of
the charm
other than that I don't know there she
is Heidi Klum made it to the Emmys
and proof we can all breathe a sigh of
relief but the one thing I am concerned
about is that there are not enough
bracelets in this look maybe next time
also that slit is close to the place